yo creo que es un buen comienzo eso
buenas tardes a todos yo creo que sí
estamos felices por el veredicto del
caso de georges duroy pero no nos
podemos acomodar porque como usted dijo
tuvimos en el caso de mike y allá que
pasó hoy y la semana pasada el caso de
donde wright esto es necesario en el
país no sólo en minneapolis sino el país
completo es tiempo para una conversación
honesta y concreta
puntos de cambio
sobre la policía en este país y más
específicamente la policía en este país
y el tratamiento hacia el hombre y la
mujer negra y ver la denuncia es
fundamental pero una de las luchas para
erradicar el racismo es contra el miedo
los afroamericanos tienen miedo cada vez
que un oficial se acerca y los policías
también sienten temor y no saben
evidentemente manejar las situaciones de
orden público cuando involucran a los
ciudadanos afro cómo se combaten ambos
estereotipos
la cosa es que no los estereotipos no
van de nuestro stereo tipos vienen de un
punto de que no han matado
estamos hablando de ellos hoy nos han
matado por casos sin sin armas con almas
caminando parando nos hemos tenido esos
incidentes donde no nos hemos podido
defender y el único odio son nosotros es
el ser negro
en este país pero en el mundo completo
la policía está siendo entrenada para
ver a las personas negras como una
amenaza esto es un punto que se tiene
que hablar como nosotros nos portamos no
tienen nada que ver con como ellos nos
ven porque inmediatamente si nos ven
como una amenaza así es como se
enfrentan con nosotros que sea algo
simple yo he estado en situaciones en
una cena hablando porque era un policía
tratar a alguien mal y teniendo una voz
inmediatamente nos tratan como si
estamos haciendo una con mucha agresión
y solo tratando de entender y tener una
conversación bueno mire y las
autoridades buscarán abusos sistemáticos
de poder cuál es la experiencia desde su
activismo de la diáspora en eeuu cómo
llegamos hasta aquí y sobre todo cómo
saltamos nuestras deudas con los
descendientes de áfrica
esto es una excelente pregunta
pero el odio
an
y negrura que existe en este país
en el mundo
está totalmente dentro de todos los
sistemas y hasta que no comencemos a
mirar estos sistemas directamente qué es
lo que está pasando cómo están haciendo
sus prácticas como hoy anunciaron sobre
la policía en minneapolis
eso tiene que hacerlo con la policía con
vivienda con la tierra con las escuelas
con una medicina con los hospitales
mujeres negras mueren más rápidos en los
hospitales jóvenes en las escuelas están
siendo más estaban hablando con más
agresión por ser negros
eso es una conversación que si estamos
en frente a lo que está pasando con la
relación de la policía con la comunidad
pero ese mismo racismo ese mismo odio
esa misma falta de reparaciones de
reparar
el daño que todavía existe desde los
tiempos de ser esclavizados no se ha
hecho honestamente
y querer salir y decir si tenemos que
reparar estos sistemas mira muchísimas
gracias por entregarnos su perspectiva
en la materia